the Indianapolis Star did a survey of
the most important sports event of the
last century and the Milan Muncie
Central game was number one
Oh
I'm Bobby plump and I'm the real-life
Jimmy Chitwood we had a thousand seat
gymnasium the town was 1100 we have
thousand season ticket holders when we
were playing the sport of basketball of
course was everything you know we had a
local theater but it closed on Friday
night because nobody would go I tried to
capture the time in the place Hoosiers
is about the relationship between
basketball in high school basketball in
Indiana and the people I think the movie
was based on the Milan story the Milan
story that David beat Goliath
Jimmy saved the coach's job by playing
Jean white said we saved a coaching job
by winning there was similarity between
Jimmy Chitwood and Bobby plump only that
there was one star shooter we were the
leaders on the team except I wasn't
nearly as outspoken as he was I don't
think Bobby would have ever got up in
front of the church and said you know
I'm coming back to play and coaches got
to stay when I was in grade school I
think and if I could just sit on the
bench for a varsity my life's complete
the year before we were in the state
finals and that meant a lot to the town
of Milan going into the tournament we
had lost two ball games
we ended up 18 and two during the season
the championship game was David versus
Goliath Muncie Central was a heavy favor
they were a school of about 2000 we were
a school about 160 they had won more
tournaments and still have one more
tournament than anybody we never went on
the court ever thinking we were going to
lose we never went on the court ever
thinking we were
when either the fieldhouse would seat
about 15,000 2,000 of them were for
Muncie and 13,000 of them were for mine
they estimated 90% of the adult
population listened or watched that day
just as in the movie 18 seconds to go
30 to 30 15,000 fans screaming their
heads off and they're waiting for me to
do something didn't say like Jimmy I'm
going to make it or all that Bobby was
the right person to take the last shot I
faked here and I went through to here
right at the edge of the free-throw line
and I shot a jump shot and fortunately
it went in Bobby basket was a stone that
conquered Goliath on that night
instantaneous thrill nothing can compare
to it when we came home they estimate
there were 40,000 people - we hit
Shelbyville we have to go through their
town again to Milan they met us with
fire trucks police cars people were
lining the sidewalks curious as we went
through to me that's what Indiana
basketball was all about Hoosier
hysteria was a small school leaving the
large I was awarded that rest your award
for mental attitude and scholarship was
a member of the winning team and was
named mr. basketball and there had never
been a person with all three of those
until 1954 and has only been to six the
reality is that things are still
happening after all these years and I
think that's part of the reason that the
story continues as the movie came out
it kind of perpetuated the story again
the movies kept the story of life
there's no question about that ending
the movie with the same shot that won us
the state championship is great I think
that Bobby shot is the the single most
important moment in Indiana high school
basketball history it represented
something that was unique about
basketball in Indiana I have been
extremely fortunate there's been a lot
of players that have hit last shots and
things mine seemed to last a long time
and not seeing that has lasted a long
time it's only been right 61 years